ich möchte anfang mit einem thema das
mich heute aufgeregt hat beim blick auf
das sondierungsteam der grünen die
grünen die predigen uns immer vielfalt
ist wichtig für unser land vielfalt
brauchen wir vielfalt ist toll aber wenn
man sich jetzt anschaut wäre dort im
sondierungsteam der grünen sitzt dann
erkennt man da gibt's keine vielfalt da
sind nur weiße menschen frauen und
männer und was noch auffällt das ist
dass es niemanden gibt der zum beispiel
einen migrationshintergrund hätte wie
cem özdemir der noch dazu sein wahlkreis
gewonnen hat der ein erfahrener
außenpolitiker ist für mich zeigt sich
darin die ganze doppelmoral der grünen
auf der einen seite will man uns
erzählen dass wir alle vielfältig sein
müssen aber dann wenn es drauf ankommt
also wenn man aus der opposition in
richtung regierung rutscht in die
sondierung dann ist es plötzlich verlegt
begann freilich fest gar nicht warum du
da jetzt so verwundert es ehrlich gesagt
also die doppelmoral dafür steht ja die
grüne partei schlechthin ich meine die
machen umweltschutz genauso lange wie es
in ihr programm passt also schön bei
anfang aber nein wenn dann morgen den
termin beim anwalt ist wo man schnell
gehen muss wird natürlich auch im land
geflogen und das ist ja eigentlich so
dieses dass das geniale an im grünen ist
ja genau dass diese doppelmoral wäre sie
damit auch noch durchkommen ich meine
die grünen sind ja eigentlich mit der
angepassten trupp von allen machen aber
immer ein auf rebellen und schaffen als
einzige noch gegen ihre eigenen gesetze
zu demonstrieren die doppelmoral hat man
auch während corona gemerkt auf der
einen seite wollten die grünen mit dh
dass maßnahmen haben es aber auch
geschafft ja mit dem moralischen
zeigefinger darauf hinzuweisen dass man
bitte auf die grundrechte achtet und für
mich ist das was da gerade jetzt
passiert absolut typisch wieder viel
grün die halten es eigentlich mit jeder
maßnahme von wegen was interessiert mich
mein geschwätz von gestern und kommen
damit durch das ist ja das geniale an
wir müssen unser zuschauern vielleicht
noch erklären dass du hast ein buch
geschrieben warum du niemals die grünen
wählen würde es ist auch ein bisschen
teuer ist erst mal zusammengefasst ja so
heißt ich bin nicht grün ein plädoyer
für freiheit aber du würdest du trotzdem
nie wählen scheint mir zu sein
nein ich mache heute ein versprechen ich
würde die grünen wählen wenn ein fall
eintritt wenn boris palmer
kanzlerkandidat werden sollte kriegen
die grünen meine stimme der heute gesagt
hat philipp amthor dass er eine ampel
sieht boris palmer aber wie sehen sie
die grünen in diesem video naja der
boris palmer lag häufig richtig hier
hätte ich mir gewünscht dass er auch die
chancen sieht die ein jamaika bündnis
für die grünen hätte denn ich glaube da
könnten sie durchaus auch zeigen dass
man die ganze vielfalt in einer
koalition abbilden kann von
wirtschaftsliberalen themen bei der fdp
die mitte der gesellschaft bei der cdu
auch mit dem bürgerlich konservativen
akzent und eben dann das vermeintlich
progressive bei den grünen ich glaube
jedenfalls es wäre herausfordernder aber
böte auch mehr eine chance wenn sie in
jamaika bündnis eingehen man muss es
jetzt sehen was die inhaltlichen
forderungen sind am ende verkaufen
dürfen bei uns in etwaigen sondierung
nicht es gibt überschneidungen aber gibt
aus meiner sicht auch ein paar no go's
mit den grünen und dabei muss es bleiben
also wenn ich für sehr hoch interessant
ist diese marke will ist schön
shakespeareschen intrigen rahmen auch
noch mit dem destabilisiert toraus bei
ihren dem herrn söder der da auch noch
mit seiner pump action da etwas einfluss
nimmt in der deutschen politik wenn ich
die grünen wäre dort schweizer kann ich
mich an jede gefühlslage perfekt hinein
denken muss ich sagen eigentlich müsste
herr habeck darauf hinarbeiten mit der
cdu eine koalition zu machen warum meine
vordergründig würde man sagen klar die
grünen und die roten die die linken
haben in großen übereinstimmung aber die
grünen haben ja kein interesse unter
einem olaf scholz der die spd wieder in
die mitte führt und zu einer vielleicht
verblichenen früheren größe führen kann
etwas weg aus diesem ätherischen säcke
davon frau esken und ein borjans aber
das ist
okay das finde ich das ist einmal das
hast du richtig gesagt das ist natürlich
das große problem dass dort natürlich
irgendwie wasser gepredigt und wein
getrunken und die partei natürlich auch
macht mut mäßig unterwegs ist aber
vielleicht noch mein punkt und dem
fertig zu machen
ich glaube die grünen könnten sich ja
mit einem etwas geschwächten kanzler
laschet wenn sie die erste linke geige
in diese jamaika-koalition spielen
könnten sie sich eigentlich eher
profilieren das heißt die frage welche
konstellation sieht man auch für mich
also jamaika aus sicht der grünen
attraktiv aber das mit der vielfalt da
kann ich nicht widersprechen das stimmt
natürlich frisch und total dass die
grünen ja früher für die basisdemokratie
waren hinten kaum kommen sie in die nähe
der macht und hoffen sie dass still und
leise
wenn wir über koalitionen sprechen von
bus bahn oder bus bahn man sieht in den
sondierungsteams cem özdemir ist nicht
dabei aber dafür ricarda lang claudia
roth das sind ja ehrennamen wo man
denken würde na ja richtung jamaika geht
das eher nicht oder er hat die
vielfältige ist das eine was wir haben
bei den grün was wir auch beobachten da
muss ich lena ein stück weit wieder
sprechen tatsächlich ausnahmsweise dass
sie damit durchkommen ich habe nicht den
eindruck dass sie damit durchkommen die
bauern viele luftschlösser und die
mensch die bürgerinnen und bürger auch
die wähler haben uns am sonntag gezeigt
dass man damit auf dauer das
funktioniert nicht du kannst eben genau
dieses prinzip
wein und wasser geht langfristig nicht
gut das ganze versuchen als taktisches
kalkül aber man sieht es doch ich habe
von anfang an gesagt bleibt entspannt
bei den grünen die werden sich schon
selber ein zauber mit der zeit muss so
gar nicht viel machen muss einfach reden
was laut verlass und genau das passiert
aber da muss ich sagen annalena baerbock
ich glaube doch dass sie damit
durchkommen ich glaube nämlich zb wenn
es eine robert habeck robert habeck
gewehr gegner gewesen dem er geschichten
ja aber mit einer in der bergung ist hat
die größten seifenblase von allen
zerplatzt aber ich glaube es war eher
eine wahl gegen annalena baerbock als
eine wahl gegen die grünen ich glaube
ich würde mich zu der these hinreißen
lassen wenn robert habeck aufgestellt
worden wäre werden sie bei über 20
prozent gewesen das ist übrigens auch
wieder eine frau hügel und innerhalb der
innerhalb der grünen partei nicht nur
dass sie jetzt keine vielfalt drin haben
sondern weil sich ja total ist was für
mich eher gegen jegliche
gleichberechtigung ist ist ja dieses
wenn eine frau die hand hier wird ist
die frau
was das denn wie das bei uns nicht haben
dass wir klar wir versuchen menschen
nach leistung zu fördern aber nicht
nachher nicht nach herkunft geschlecht
und all diesen dingen ist da nix und das
verrückte ist ja sogar bei den grünen
das ist ein vielfalt statt
achja ich dass es dieses mal will man
sich das anschaut also dann da weiß man
gar nicht mehr also wenn man sich dann
die das sondierungsteam angesetzt sagen
alle ja im erweiterten sondierungsteam
wollen wie 30 oder 40 leute sind am ende
da wäre ja zum beispiel cem özdemir dann
dabei aber das sind doch schon ziemlich
absurde ausreden was was woran liegt das
also ja also das würde ich auch so sehen
im übrigen habe ich den eindruck wo die
flügel der grünen hans so möchte
verfängt da sehen wir auch da gibt es
immer unterschiedliche lebensrealitäten
über den küchentischen und über dem wie
wir es dann in der politischen
diskussion sehen also ich habe den
eindruck dass mancher da dann nur zu
zurückhaltend wäre das anzusprechen es
gibt ja oft so richtig bei fremden
gegenüber den grünen habe ich den
eindruck stehen er und ich sehe das ganz
genauso also ich habe das oft gesehen
wenn man dann auch gegenüber den grünen
ein klares wort findet dann kriegst im
öffentlich rechtlichen im zweifel keinen
applaus aber über den küchentischen in
vorpommern sieht das anders aus und das
projekt ja also ich muss wirklich sagen
in dem haus der wahlkampf den ich
dahinter mehr hat paris erfolgreich
waren das lag nicht am haustür wahlkampf
will ich mal sagen mein persönliches
ergebnis war dann schon ein bisschen
besser gereicht hat es nicht aber ich
mich sehr geärgert im wahlkreis aber aus
dem wahlkampf fand ich schon immer gut
war kriegst du sehr direkt was die leute
so bewegt die größte angst war wirklich
vor den grünen also das hauptthema war
nicht die leute ein wenig die tür
aufgemacht und haben gesagt ohne die und
ja ich kann die cdu nicht wählen weil
die zu wenig gender sprache adressiert
sondern lehrt haben die job gemacht und
gesagt um gottes willen einer hat mir
gesagt zwar nicht besonders gut ich habe
angst wenn ich die grünen wähle da kann
ich meinen autoschlüssel gleich mit in
die wahlurne werfen so und das ist eher
die leben also wenn ich hier noch was
sie zufügen kann ich bin ja eigentlich
ein ehemaliger grüner also dass die
grünen hört man jetzt nicht mehr so gar
nicht also ich bin einfach grün weiß du
bei mir kannst du trotzen und das bleibt
grün bei vielen grünen kommt erlegen
waren sehr schnell rot zum vorschein
aber die grünen waren nach meldungen in
deutschland in rodas insbesondere das
war eigentlich bei diesen grünen noch
das faszinierende die sind ja in diesen
riesigen deutschen polit betrieb der
eingefahren und haben da etwas
frischluft und anarchischen
widerspruchsgeist gebracht und das was
mir jetzt von außen etwas auffällt ist
dass diese grünen mit ausnahmen wie
palmen und das spricht ja eigentlich
wieder für die grünen dass sie solche
leute in ihren reihen immer irgendwie
haben
den song als okay aber das problem der
grünen besteht meiner ansicht nach darin
dass dieses anarcho element das ist
irgendwie verloren gegangen heute sind
die grünen in wien zu einer klassischen
macht partei geworden ich hab das hast
du gesagt hast vorhin das sind genauso
indizien man versucht zwar irgendwie
noch so zu wirken wie man vielleicht
einmal war aber wenn es dann hart auf
hart zugeht dann ist man wie die anderen
parteien über die man sich früher lustig
gemacht und ich bedauere dass das dieses
anadarko moment hier fehlt deshalb muss
diese runde selbstverständlich muss
natürlich diese talkshow dieses
anarchische element ein solches projekt
wieder hinein wir versprechen wir
bleiben ja na ja
[Musik]